hello gamespot com the website were
three white dudes wearing blue shirts
all across their legs in the exact same
manner I'm wearing red sox who you are
you're wearing red socks you're also
going to blue shirts Aparri Marty
flexible I'm way to blue shirts but my
real intention was to do this do that
duh could star wars man star wars how
appropriate ah it's not worth bought
from said today officially you reviewed
it yep when did your of you go up last
night and nine that's funny because I
was playing it oh yeah yeah ah da access
yeah xsy was like 10 hours yeah 10 hours
yeah yeah so like yeah we got I was
playing it like a retail copy and then
it was I completely forgot that like EA
access would have liked there be a drop
off before it actually released so I was
wondering why see this seems really kind
of unpopulated bright suppose the last
four days yeah but yeah Rob's now you
were playing a bunch last week you
requested a massive stream on this couch
six hours last week first of all before
I asked Mike way gave a 7 out of 10 what
do you think of star wars battlefront
does a fan of like first-person shooter
games and massive star wars huge fan of
battlefield huge Star Wars fan so you
think those would coincide pretty well
and they do you know it's just how long
will I will have you enjoying it yeah
i'm currently enjoying it still love it
I mean it still has these it still
retains these moments where you know a
tight fire will come out of sky blow up
right in front of you and it sounds and
looks spectacular it is eye candy up the
wazoo and i love it and i still get
those highs like in these moments right
but we were talking about it and they
kind of start drifting off all right and
you know there's i'm gonna let him talk
about the progression and how the
longevity just simply is not doesn't
that seems like the bottom right because
it looks it looks and sounds even if
someone who's not a massive star respond
super legit like it's it's the way you
want to star wars game to look and said
if you're a fan but it just it's not the
depth isn't there right right because
there's nine game modes and each of them
are pretty different I mean the my
favorite to our supremacy
in Walker assault Walker salsa when
they're really telling and you see
someone beating the [ __ ] out Vader
Walker Saul is the most the the one
where you actually that's like their
unique one we're it's like kind of
attack and defend almost but then it's
they're actually using those iconic you
know the 8080 is coming at you and the
it used to be pretty imbalance in the
beta but now it's my favorite mode they
do join things to make it like even
better for the rebels and everything
what are the types of modes supremacy
which is kinda like a tug of war zone
capture then they have a droid run which
is like domination but it's the droid so
they wander around the map so there's no
static pointing to Hill King yeah it's
like yeah king of the hill almost and
then you know they have Fighter Squadron
which is all viet just vehicles airborne
like ships and then you have just like
the classics cargo is pretty much
capture the flag which is it's fun but
it's not too new or anything but the
thing is like despite how many gay modes
there are none of them get too deep
walker salt i love and i still want to
keep playing it but everything else like
Fighter Squadron right here you see you
feel like you've seen everything after
about an hour in each one sure like like
towards the end I'm I'm just sticking to
supremacy and Walker salt um that's are
like the big modes right the big modes
where you get you get to the entire
experience that you want you what you
want everything for the most part but
you know you get these kind of these
these half ass foes my opinion you know
like a hero hunt where it's just not
thought out where it wrong it's you you
take turns becoming the hero so I played
a couple times this mode and the idea is
that it's it's one team and you if you
like if I'm the last guy to if I kill
hero and i become the hero and then i
could rain terror it is basically a
free-for-all with team play trend like l
because everyone for themselves but
they're all shooting the same thing yeah
edward what happens is like yeah i was
late i like their couple rounds i could
not kill the hero because you he'll kill
me seconds away from him dying then
someone else comes in swoops in the
kills like last hit yeah exactly and it
was frustrating and i like that was it I
was like no interest applying that again
here's Palpatine doing barrel rolls haha
you know just like a weird see that's
yeah and II liked how they shop out
teen's death in their game they're like
why is everyone still fighting thank you
wars over
we've won yeah and is the problem that
it's like what even with all this
variety game owes the game itself like
in terms of you controlling our
character is super basic like you you
have one bucket of shoes you pick up
power-ups that are sort of floating
around the world it's not like something
like battlefield for instance where
you're loading at a character would like
four different things right yeah cuz
that's I mean you could say a lot of
online multiplayer is can be repetitive
mmm but in this like you play halo not
to compare the two but you have halos
momentum on combat so fun and it can
unfold differently each way there's a
lot of emergent gameplay yeah in this
the vast majority of firefights it comes
down and I mention this in the review
it'll come down to two people see each
other and you'll start just you'll push
the trigger and hold it and depending on
how slightly better you're a might be
exactly the one that walks away exactly
and the blasters this feeds into this is
kind of a problem with a progression
system as well a lot of the blasters
aside from one being automatic the next
being you know semi the next being kind
of a shotgun in a way they're all very
similar so you feel like you're just
kind of playing the same way over and
over like the modes are changing how you
play and the good modes really can lead
to some of that emergent stuff but by
and large it just after about after a
while playing anything especially a team
deathmatch I just I don't want to go
back to those is it wrong that threat
whatever Isaac updates six hours in
total I never upgraded my blaster cuz oh
yeah I bought a new one yeah it felt
fine to me yeah like there was nothing
about it that I felt oh well maybe like
less recoil yes that's what it really is
its recoil I just out of going like
pressing pressing pressing instead of
holding it down right as to compensate
yeah I mean that's the thing and that's
like the only like I would have loved to
have seen types of progression in like
vehicles right like hmm like what I
loved about I mean I have to compare to
like battlefield 3 and 4 is like cool
I'm gonna I'm just gonna fly and we're
gonna do is I'm gonna upgrade my weapons
on this on this crap time gonna get
better photon torpedoes whatever you
want to do it there isn't anything like
that like it's just simply this infantry
it's really a fat rebase right and like
you know you're fine around you get shot
down pretty quick but you're not you're
not really present and yeah the most
part not as much as you'd like to be
you'd like you'd like to have some
involvement you know
some chat would be nice like hey we need
air support you know like it's missing
funds I it's it sounds like the bottle
is just sort of happening and you
you're-you're there rather than really
you know impacting it right it feels
much more like you're spectating in a
way and then you happen to come across
these little fire fights but I never
really aside from a few times Walker
assault and supremacy I never felt like
I was really impacting the battle if I
was doing really well and getting a few
kills without dying which this games
pretty hard to not die and because again
it's just these exchanging laser like
exchanging blaster fire and everything
and yeah it's it doesn't ever feel like
I had a clear sense of what was I mean I
knew what we're supposed to be doing but
I wasn't sure how it was going aside
from you know the kill counter at the
top yeah kind of an indication but I
never really felt like I was like okay
I'm gonna get on the speeder bike I'm
gonna go to their back outpost me to
take and then I'm gonna come help my
buddies at this one it was always just
I'll just see what happens it's just
chaos because then that's the thing to
write is you have these power weapons
and options on the field but you aren't
picking them yeah you're just given them
so if you are if I died like okay well
let me let me handle this differently
let me get a rocket launcher and take
out that 80's teen know you got first
off you gotta find this icon cross your
fingers maybe I'll get a rock launch 10
you get a dome you get a dome shield
you're like great and burn that and then
you try to find another one it's just
there's no yeah it's just chaos yeah you
like to you know find a way like a play
style I'm gonna do this I'm gonna pay
buddy you know let's take out this thing
like that's our agency in the bottle
yeah it's weird you say that because i
was at once i was trying to like rush to
stop them taking an objective and i ran
into one of the like thai fighter like
pickups and I was like well I was
actually going to help over here but
like I have to pick this they go but
have a go it's like it actually kind of
[ __ ] the strategy I had right on the
other side that and that has this is
actually I thought I found really weird
is um there's one icon that you pick up
that basically if I had a burn card like
the ion shot the idea is that yes you
see in the bottom right there it's like
a kinda like a recycling sign when I
throw that i use the iron shot i can
throw this on and can recharge quicker
hmm but i had this issue were
in the earlier phases of the game you
don't get a burn card you have to work
for it to like from like 125 or some
like that so I pick up this icon I can't
get rid of it because I'm no but I think
it burn yeah I go to the swing I'm like
I can't get this i can't ever do they
have this to a burger you cannot get rid
of it yeah the only ones i think you can
swap out in certain cases a hero ones
but you come across those yeah that's a
nightmare another one is like it's just
these issues like oh cool there's an
x-wing we're down the mountain Luke's
helping out so mano this is the time
it's like oh there's an x-wing down over
here but there are a PST's and troops
surrounding it and it's down the mopin
on the open yours like all right I will
die but I'm gonna make an effort because
I'd like to fly an x-wing you never know
so it sounds like a good game a great
guy very fun at first but it's just a
limited red bananas as it can be you're
still gonna come across those moments in
the first 10 hours you're like I'm Luke
Skywalker I just cut an eight EST in
half it might have stomped on me
afterwards but in order to do it off a
cliff yeah that was create into the TIE
fighter or you did one yeah cuz there's
that there's that gift for the Luke
Skywalker force pushing someone into a
TIE fighter as it flies by the craziest
thing I've done and tay doesn't believe
me i need to actually go back and find
the footage on my ps4 at home i was
standing on a cliff on Hoth and han Solo
has this really ridiculous shoulder
charge yeah it's fun to do but it's kind
of dumb in a great way but a TIE fighter
was flying by like trying to just shoot
me in the face and all of a sudden it
pulled out of the last second by did my
shoulder charge and he must have been
like oh hell no way I'll bring it in
well I'll I'll find something I'll find
it maybe you dreamt that yeah it was
great and it blew up fun last question
it looks pretty good on consoles and
guys seen it on PC yeah i've been
playing at pc look right now and it
looks really good yeah we're trying to
get it to run a 4k with lectern awesome
settings at UK it's like already do all
right I have to say also is you know as
someone who loves Star Wars what I am
looking forward to with this game is I
think I just found out today or the
other days they kind of released a
statement that they're gonna have all
this DLC and it's like some like 16 maps
yeah yes or no you have shocked ooh
that's coming up that's good so that I
think they're really seeing it like by
like jock who obviously is gonna have
more than one map on it right so I'm not
sure how many but its total they're
planning all right right for planets now
and then most of the each game mode on
each map has its own like variant of the
map so there's a bunch of maps cool but
I'm kind of looking for I mean exactly
and so it's gonna be cool to at least I
mean you know you these these DLC
packages are gonna come out and you'd be
like cool let's try it out a couple
hours All Right see you later that's how
it's gonna go but I am a little curious
see all these gonna look right yeah cuz
I i well I imagine they're also going to
be really similar to the movie you know
jakku is a battle that happened like I
maybe they'll pull on that a lot so I'll
see you happen to be pretty interesting
oh yeah good fan service to the Star
Wars fence like very much don't be a
some gameplay up on gamespot com later
on today yeah awesome all right let us
know what you think of Star Wars
Battlefront are you a star wars fan or
about a big fan are you excited or
disappointed like leave your thoughts in
the comment box below